weil so wie ich das zurzeit kaum ein
schatten ich bin batman in batman und
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu minecraft galaxy
ist relativ spät für die erde ein erstes
video heute ich weiß also aller jagoda
ich gesagt dass ich jeden tag zwei
videos bringen gute sache wird wohl nix
wenn so ein kleiner hören so die
kritiker schießen in einem youtube leben
also soll ich in lake city dna nackig
die dann ein
jetzt nehme ich noch ein becher milch
sondern meine drei mal hier haben was
ich sagen wollte war dass ich heute zwar
schon um 10 uhr aufgestanden bin aber
das ganze liegt auch daran dass ich
gestern schon neun gängen bin warum luca
bist du um 9 und bett gegangen
wir hatten freibier und ja das hab ich
mir dann heute zu herzen genommen dann
waren wir ein bisschen feiern und dann
war ich relativ schnell auch relativ
müde bin dann nach hause gefahren und
ich habe wirklich 14 stunden geschlafen
und ich wusste nicht dass das in meiner
macht steht dass sich dazu in der lage
bin 14 stunden zu schlafen lief bei mir
auf jeden fall muss ich sagen ich 14
stunden geschlafen und war danach immer
noch müde
das ist ein phänomen bei mir egal wie
viel ich schlafe dauerhaft müde
dauerhaft total fertig rodgau
nee also keine ahnung ich weiß nicht
warum ich immer müde bin aber es ist
irgendwie so und ich mache jetzt eine
quelle fällt mir gerade mal auf ich
hätte das wasser von oben nehmen können
ich kleine [ __ ] solch böse weiter
hier immer noch so wie ihn jetzt einfach
das wasser hier wollen sich dass hier
wieder hin
ja ich wollte mich quasi damit jetzt nur
eben bei euch entschuldigen dass ich
weiß nicht wie die musik hört aber wir
machen hier gleich fußball gucken weil
gleiche tier auch schon fußball los und
da gleich fußball losgeht werde ich
heute auch kein zweites video mehr
hinkriegen
es tut mir leid dass ich euch immer
sachen verspreche in meinem leben und
dich nicht einhalten kann weil ich ein
verdammter vollidiot bin der nicht
geschissen gericht in seinem leben
es tut mir aber echt total leid dass ich
euch quasi verspreche dass zwei videos
täglich kommen und es kommt einfach
alles andere zwei videos tägliches kommt
einfach mal nur ein video
ich versuche mir den arsch aufzureißen
dafür und in einer gewissen form ist es
ja auch so quasi mein beruf also ich bin
jetzt nicht hauptberuflich youtuber ich
bin ja schüler und student aber es ist
halt gerade deswegen so dass ich nein
alles falsch mache es ist gerade
deswegen so dass ich halt noch andere
dinge zu tun habe in meinem leben und
ich hoffe ihr respektiert das ist ich
finde es aber selber scheiße von mir
dass ich euch sage dass zwei videos pro
tag kommen und es kommt nichts mehr
videos pro tag das tut mir an der stelle
leid ich hoffe ihr akzeptiert da meine
entschuldigung wir müssen es akzeptieren
weil auch wenn jetzt nicht akzeptiert
kann es mir scheiß egal sein
nein quatsch ich find's super toll wenn
wir das akzeptieren würde aber naja das
freibad nicht so gut verlaufen für mich
also ich habe mich irgendwie gemault ich
war nicht so toll aber ich habe mich
wirklich einfach gebaut man kann sich
auch mal und maulen ohne dass alkohol im
spiel ist und war beim arzt deswegen und
wie geht's eigentlich total ich bin
total fit der fit und freue mich gleich
weit wie pizza bestellen und fußball
gucken und bieten eine oder andere
bierchen hochheben aber es ist ein
bisschen doof dass ich das gefühl habe
dass hier das ich gar nicht mehr fühlt
das ist trotzdem so ein bisschen doof
gelaufen alles keine kontrolle hier mehr
es ist ein bisschen scheiße dass mein
fuß total wie ich kann ich richtig
auftreten
das ist halt alles nicht so ich habe mir
das nicht so vorgestellt wiesbaden und
ich glaube ich erzähler total im
bullshit weil ich einfach schon wieder
alleine aufnehmen ich muss mir meine
freunde suchen mit denen ich aufnehme
male die nächste videos werden
wahrscheinlich mit sturmfluten und der
crew das zusammensein und das wird dann
ganz cool und solche arbeiten wollte ich
ja eigentlich in stunden folgen immer
machen aber ich hab mir gedacht da ich
jetzt ein bisschen erziehen möchte macht
das einfach jetzt und zwar wollte ich
ein wenig über die fifa reden diesen
scheiß copen arschloch ich habe ganz
einfach so gedacht dass mir wenn ich die
fahrräder weil ich mir gar nicht ein
thema zu recht suchen wollte aber dass
man mit dem manne folge füllen könnte
und da ist jetzt einfach passend zur wm
ist mir die fifa eingefallen die ja
nicht so cool ist die fifa also ihr
denkt zwei wodka blabla aber im
hintergrund sterben 10
jahren arbeiter dabei die ganze stadion
zu errichten die nur für eine wm
gebraucht werden danach einfach herum
stehen vier südafrika und die ganze
länder werden quasi dazu gezwungen diese
stadien zu bauen wenn irgendwie sowas in
deutschland ist einer wm in deutschland
oder so finde ich das super oder spanien
oder portugal oder england oder
niederlande so fußball nation italien wo
halt sonst auch fußball gespielt wird
und wo man keine stadien errichten
müssen die arbeitsbedingungen nicht
scheiße sind und alles mögliche an
welchen super fan davon
ich bin auch fern vom fußball also das
ist mir egal
das hört sich kaka an also das ist mir
egal wie viele leute sterben
nein quatsch das ist halt einfach so das
ist für die leute nicht cool ist wenn
sie sterben
das ist wirklich cool für die und diese
ganze scheiße von wegen jahr kommen wir
sind die fifa wir sind so toll wir sind
wir machen gar keinen gewinnen und sowie
blablabla da denke ich mir immer so was
in gottes namen soll das weil diese fifa
ist die einzige das einzige unternehmen
das gewinn macht die das land macht gar
keinen gewinn machen vielleicht gewinnen
dadurch dass ein paar currywürste vom
stadion verkaufen
jetzt habe ich so bock auf currywurst
gar nicht alltäglich pc dadurch machen
die gewinnen den ganzen gewinn macht die
fifa die fifa dass es leise nicht die
weltmeisterschaft 2022 2002 auf englisch
dazu erwähnen
hallo gebäuden normal was schreiben hier
nie aufnehmen was machen ich wollte mir
mein motto in sakura butt wir auch noch
die macht dadurch lege ich ein bisschen
kannte steuern kann es sein dass clegg
der wie ich gesagt dass ich vom server
fliege gut habe ich den ganzen gewinn
macht hallo macht die fifa die
weltmeisterschaft 2022 ist in
mensch ist auch hier die
weltmeisterschaft 2022 in katar und
katar ist ein land wo es
durchschnittlich 50 grad warm sind
wenn wir mal jemand sagen soll wieder
eine wm stattfinden soll ja dann sagt
mir das mal
also ich gehe da ja nicht euch an das
hört sich vielleicht ein bisschen so an
weil es ein bisschen doof gelaunt bin
ich bin ich mal doof gelaunt aber auch
alt als ich das so alles zu mit einer
mit der zeit der zu erfahren habe was
sehr viel find ich finde scheiß
organisation ist hatte ich auf jeden
fall weniger lust auf die wm
natürlich ist fußball geil und bla bla
bla bla bla aber wenn man einfach mit
dem hintergedanken
das schaut und sieht zwar die ganzen
fans wieder im stadion sitzen und so was
aber wenn man sich einfach mal überlegt
dass wir so viele menschen bei gestorben
sind diese stadien zu erreichen und
alles mögliche dann trübt das doch
gleich meine lust und da wollt jetzt
kommt mal einfach drüber reden weil
deutschland gleich spielt und hier kommt
schon die ersten gäste eintrudeln und
ich wollte da soll ich das glas in bau
oder zäune
ich bin mir nicht sicher ich will
eigentlich nicht alles so total offen
gehalten sondern da so ein bisschen glas
noch dran bauen aber zu einer hab ich
halt ne ich hab's halt leute ich hab ja
ich hab's aber auch an glas das ja super
diese andere bäume muss ich auch nochmal
nach pflanzen
das gericht ich denke schon
kommt
kompakt den dahin einfach um eine
männerhand tutor ich habe überall so
rothe wunden so richtig kleine rote wo
man sich so denkt so
das kann man gar nicht weh tun aber es
brennt so total das ist also ein
bisschen ungarn
ich wünsche einfach ich man könnte so
die zeit zurückspulen soll das also toll
dann hätte ich mich nicht gemauert
sondern wir alles gut gewesen
ja keine ahnung wie sondern bitte bei 50
grad
fussball hallo schild da ist ein super
tollen platz nein man wie soll man bitte
bei 50 grad fußball spielen die
arbeitsbedingungen dort sind so unter
aller sau
da werden 10.000 an leuten sterben nur
weil sie die stadien errichten
das ist unglaublich krass das ist das
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
dafür finde ich auch überhaupt kein
verständnis für sonst schwachsinn
das ist das unnötigste was ich in meinem
ganzen leben
könnt ihr einen dass das unnötigste was
ich meinem ganzen leben gehört habe dass
die fifa wm in katar ist desweiteren
alle fans müssen nach katar fliegen weil
es karthane riesige fußball nation nein
die können sich nicht mehr titels
leisten verdient der stadien tickets
werden ja wieder so 70 80 euro kosten
für diese blöde wm in katar
und dann sind da die ganzen leute ja
gearbeitet haben und alles mögliche
gemacht haben haben da nichts vom die
können ja nicht einfach hin und dann so
sagen ja komm ich habe das hier
errichtet ich will jetzt mal schauen
die sonne also verstehe was meine
benders installation ist wie kann man
das ganz cool ich denke ich denke die
karten bei der sonder nation ist wie
deutschland oder holland oder irgendwo
wo die leute sich das muss erstens eine
fußballbegeisterte nation ist wo die
arbeitsbedingungen in ordnung sind
wo die klimatischen bedingungen in
ordnung sind
also das sind ja diese standortfaktoren
einfahrt ist sehr weich und harte
standortfaktoren weiche sind ja welche
die man so leicht messen kann
also sowas wie klimatische bedingungen
und harte standortfaktoren ist sowas wie
ja so was was man so die so die
politische lage in einem land uns was
man halt nicht gerade messen kann man
halt darüber was sagen kann aber was man
nicht gerade messen kann weil beim team
anzusehen okay durch den titel seien
bleibe bleiben denn diese
standortfaktoren alle stimmen dann wäre
es super toll aber das stimmt nicht
das ist ein bisschen kacke das war
übrigens auch mal kröner wenn den ganzen
blöcke auf dem wasser schwimmen würden
anstatt dass sie untergehen
wer auch cool wie witzig eine fledermaus
schwimmt erfolg nötig haben
das muss stimmen damit ihr für mich eine
wm sinn ergibt weil so wie ich das
zurzeit kaum ein schatten ich bin batman
in batman es aussieht könnte die musik
gleich wird fußballgeschäft ist übrigens
sehr sehr schön fällt mir da auch noch
eine leiter die da so cool gilt der
untergang
robert stark
wer für ihn okay cool gefällt mir ja ich
finde einfach dass das ganze keinen sinn
ergibt
in solchen ländern die die fifa zu
wiegen die suchen sich nur länder wo sie
viel zu geringe wo sie zu geringen
preisen zu geringen löhnen produzieren
können stadien errichten können und dann
einfach weil sie nicht das meiste geld
wie nur eben möglich da diskutiert der
keiner drüber als wenn das jetzt eben
wieder stattfinden würde
oder so er wurde dann das meiste geld
daraus schöpfen kann deswegen das ich
finde diese fifa ist so eine
organisation
das ist unglaublich man freut sich so
doll auf diese wm
und wenn man dann einfach mal die
hintergründe weiß dann ist das ja alles
das weil sich dann habe ich auf einmal
nicht mehr so viel lust natürlich setzt
sich trotzdem dann hier wie alle anderen
und denken ja geil fußball aber dass sie
kann den fußball nicht weil die fifa
cool ist ich sag jetzt noch ganz kurz
eben für ein bisschen schatten
weil ich diese stellte aber halt überall
schilder auf gar keinen sinn zu
entziehen
da noch am baum jedoch am public poetry
nämlich damit dann sind wir auch schon
bei ai
ich wollte mich auch nochmal irgendwann
durch man komisch ist teil dadurch
graben und schauen ob da die meine
minions fast alle ausgegraben haben
dollar kommt jedoch bäume drauf auf
meinen tollen über weg den ich mir meine
ersten habe ich mit denen gebaut
mehr ich werde meine ersten folge gebaut
habe ich glaube dass man das stößt mir
so ein baum war noch kaputt so
jedenfalls mache ich das ganze jetzt
hier noch eben zu ändern danach beendet
auf die folge weil da weil danach
deutschland spielt und da möchte ich auf
jeden fall dazu gucken aber ich bin kein
fan von der fifa und ich hab dir auch
nicht bei facebook geliked das heißt in
österreich suchen
ob das denn ein konkreter gelegt habe
habe ich mich nicht so dass jetzt aber
zum abschluss hier fifa-wm scheiße
scheiße scheiße aber der sinn dass
fußball menschen verbindet und so weil
sie nicht das halt schön aber es ist
nicht schön dass der menschen sterben
weil die stadien errichten müssen weil
die für die fifa arbeiten
nein kommt zurück das war meine meinung
dazu darüber wollte reden tut mir leid
dass heute kein zweites mal kommt ich
möchte fußball gucken und bitte
akzeptiert hast aber die sagen mit
diesem tal aus blickfang und bis zum
nächsten mal